I just went to the bathroom you guys  have tampons in there I don't you had a  scale though yeah that was weird and you  had made me clock in my weight yeah just  felt rude well just lets us know you  know  oh I actually did that joke on Barstool  once because you know that's like a you  know everyone what everyone says about  that is it's true uh and uh I said that  I go you guys have a scale and I got to  say it here I'm ruining it now because  you guys thought that was original in  the moment but it was a recycle joke  that they took out because they were  like we don't want you to I'm like you  got to make fun of the facts oh yeah  come on that what you are like you guys  are making fun of it am I real you're my  first they actually had a scale in the  bathroom no no okay yeah I know they  weigh all the girls and then the ones  that you can't joke about it because  it's true yeah